i've just chaired a cobra meeting
we're very clear that could be an
imminent russian invasion of ukraine and
our first priority is protecting british
citizens british citizens need to leave
now while commercial routes are still
available the language from the us and
the uk has really escalated in terms of
the russian threat in recent days why do
you believe a russian invasion is so
imminent
well we
are fully aware that there could be
a russian invasion almost immediately
that is why british citizens do need to
leave ukraine but we are also pursuing a
path of diplomacy and de-escalation that
is why the prime minister and i are
traveling around europe this week that
is why we are working to persuade the
russians to remove their troops from the
border because a war would be disastrous
you talk about diplomatic solutions what
does that look like is it the minsk
agreement is it something else what's
the diplomatic solution here we're very
clear that russia is the aggressor in
this situation
they have a hundred thousand troops
lined up on the ukrainian borders they
need to de-escalate because it will be a
cost to russia if they invade ukraine
both in terms of the cost of a
long-running war but also the sanctions
that we would impose which would be
severe and would target oligarchs and it
would target companies across russia
critics would say that the sanctions
that the uk has considered in the past
have never been fully implemented so
this might be a lot of tough talk but in
terms of a deterrent it's pretty
ineffective we just introduced new
sanctions legislation which is the
toughest we've ever had against russia
that enables us not to just target
companies with direct effect on ukraine
but anybody or any company that has a
bearing on the russian state and that
would seriously destabilize the russian
economy the prime minister today said
that european countries need to get
nordstrom out of their bloodstream was
that a dig at germany
well the germans and indeed the
americans have been very clear that
north stream 2 would not go ahead in the
event of a russian incursion on ukraine
and the prime minister is right we do
need to reduce dependence on russian gas
in europe and find alternative sources
you talk about the renewed diplomatic
push of course your meeting with sergey
lavrov last week ended in what some
might consider a pretty insulting press
conference how did you feel after that
well i went to russia to deliver a very
clear message which is that it's russia
who is the aggressor they have a hundred
thousand troops on the ukrainian border
and if they stage an incursion into
ukraine that would have a damaging
effect on the russian people and the
russian government of course the
russians didn't like what i had to say
but i say it nevertheless and i want
them to desist and i want them to be
aware that there would be severe costs
of an invasion you say that an invasion
is imminent is there still a diplomatic
solution here
there is always a choice but that choice
is for vladimir putin he needs to
understand that there would be severe
costs
if he invades ukraine and those costs
would be felt by russian companies by
oligarchs and ultimately the russian
people he needs to de-escalate he needs
to take his troops away from the border
final one i asked before but minsk is
that a possible ais of this president
macron suggested revitalizing reviving
the minsk agreement is one way that may
avert an invasion
it's important that russia hold to what
they've agreed in the past in the 1994
budapest agreement they agreed to
protect the territorial integrity and
sovereignty of ukraine
of course we need to implement the mints
protocols but the first part of that
is that russia needs to remove their
heaven weaponry from ukraine and they
need to
create a ceasefire and they haven't done
either of those things and those are
points that i made to minister lavrov in
moscow last week foreign secretary thank
you very much thank you